who is currently on a world tour called
the eras tour Taylor Swift Taylor Swift
what does Riz mean RZ your ability to
like pick up women something like that
would have loved to know that one but no
who was the breakout star of the boy
band Instinct nickolet did I get it I'm
not sure what was it sorry in sync I
don't know it's Justus a Tiber oh okay
what does it mean to have a Fina Fina I
don't know either fake Instagram oh okay
that makes sense who's on the cover of
NHL 23 kale wait nois and Sarah nurse
what reality show was Kelly Clark
the first winner of American Idol not a
clue I finished the lyrics She said do
you love me I tell her only partly no
clue only love my bed and my mama I'm
sorry what would you use star 67 for
when making a phone call star 67 I got
no clue to block your number what's a
social media site with a yellow icon and
a ghost Snapchat Snapchat what was the
first Apple product that ever would
listened to music on iPod the uh little
iPad or little iPod who was the first
overall pick in the NBA draft this year
no clue Lama who is the first R piic in
the NBA draft in 05 you said LeBron was
03 white Howard can you give me the team
it wasn't Chris Paul Lamar odm went to
Utah no idea Andrew bogot oh okay did
you know Snapchat who won